[Music]
you gotta have cravings now because I
remember my wife and it's such a cliche
I thought that wasn't true my wife was a
vegetarian
when I got her pregnant and that's right
yeah we've had we've had sex twice and
no but I'm Susan vegetarian I remember
being at a restaurant with her and I was
eating a hamburger because I'm Irish
Catholic yeah hamburgers yeah the Sun
comes down yeah and that's eating a
hamburger and she said could I have a
little bite of that just see what it
tastes like when she was pregnant she
took my hamburger and stuffed the whole
thing in her face and has never stopped
and because she yeah she changed I
changed her over from being a vegetarian
to now she she's like Fred Flintstone
I've heard of that happening that a
veggie I'm I am an omnivore I eat both
but I had cravings for I don't know if
this is again because of the pregnancy
or just because I love ice cream but
I've been eating a lot of ice cream
pretty classic yeah yes and it's gotten
to the point where we live in New York
and the guy at the bodega like I feel
like an alcoholic but it's for Ben and
Jerry's like I go I'm ashamed to I go
there every night and the guy looks at
me and he's so kind the bodega owner and
we make eye contact and I like sort of
look away like he knows I like I like
peruse the avocados and like oh maybe
I'll get like an apple and then like of
course I'm going to the freezer I know
he knows and I said on Tuesday of like a
couple weeks ago he said I can't get ice
cream again until Friday and you have to
hold me to it and then I came in on
Thursday night and he looked at me and
he just slowly you're you're a very sick
woman what is your what is your favorite
ice cream do you have a favorite
well it's Ben and Jerry's I like Ben and
Jerry's I have an idea for an ice cream
flavor for our show how self-serving my
friend David cleek he made up his name
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt Schmidt
Schmidt oh yeah unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt oh it's not gonna take off like
what yeah no I heard it I heard it
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
yeah
that's when you see it on a lathe what
kind of so it's gonna be a mint ice
cream yeah I mean ice mint just doesn't
sound like I got to get me some Sh mint
yeah yeah
Schmidt sounds like a German word for
the village idiot forget it
sorry we killed your eyes good and
Jerry's there already we're probably a
halfway mixing it up oh and II encoder
making fun of it stop no one listens to
us no they will listen to you it won't
maybe the next show I think if everybody
goes to their local ice-cream place and
says I want the ice-cream flavor
unbreakable kimmy schmitt and demands it
it's gonna get back to the Ben & Jerry
people right that is true yeah and then
they're all high they'll make it
you